every year tvs get bigger we constantly
hear new announcements for the next big
screen sporting more and more pixels and
it's really awesome but how many pixels
do you really need i remember movies
looking pretty good on my parents tv
back in the day i mean how much could
things have really changed the very
first consumer digital video format was
actually pretty tiny by today's
standards 720 pixels by 480 pixels cute
little pixels however this was actually
higher resolution than tvs that most
people had and this kicked off a
revolution a resolution revolution
anyone could make videos at the same
resolution as the tvs in their home we
saw the next jump in resolution 1280x720
rounded out this displayed 900 000
pixels instead of dd's 300 000 pixels
but that was just a stop gap onto what
became everyone's standard hd
[Music]
1920 by 1080 the native resolution of
blu-ray it's actually 2 million pixels
on the screen hd was beautiful it seemed
like tvs were as sharp as our own eyes
but of course technology marched forward
so what's next
so next we reached 4k or ultra high
definition
3840 pixels of 2160 pixels this actually
makes for a total of 8 million pixels
400 more pixels in hdtv
4k looks super crisp in fact most
digital projectors and theaters are 4k
so you're actually getting cinema
quality on your tv but the resolution
insanity didn't stop we got even more
it was insane we got 5k
6k
8k
so many pixels
so where does this put us let's take a
moment and let's zoom all the way back
into our little video from years ago
and let's compare
that's pretty impressive
do we need so many pixels well there's
actually a science behind all this the
human eye can resolve about 50 pixels
per inch at about six feet away if your
tv is going to be larger and 70 inches
and be within 10 feet of you 4k makes
sense smaller than that and regular
1080p will treat you just fine so let me
know in the comments below what you guys
think and what else do you value in a
television color brightness
inputs
a nice remote control let me know i'd
love to see what you guys think and
until then i'll see you in the next
video
thanks for watching and if you haven't
yet consider subscribing